two people have asked should review
their work and you see one has perfect
structure appropriate arcs syntax
grammar etc and the other one is more
rough around the edges but it displays
characters that are so real that the
reader does not really care first of all
I would love to have those two clients
as a consultant because I could work
with either one of them and sort of
figure out well how can I help you pull
up the other side that you're struggling
with it's very hard and I couldn't say
with any degree of accuracy this one
will succeed in this one will fail
because there are two such critical
elements on the one hand I think the
person who's mastered the craft and in
your words has perfect structure and
assuming that they're structuring a
really commercial idea they're in a
certainly probably further along because
then we just have to go deeper with
those characters and start really
getting into what is this identity
essence tug of war what is the wound
what is the fear what is the persona
that they've created and how does it
relate to the goal so the script is
going to read better in that case but
there are some writers who just don't
get that they just don't really have an
interest or a desire or they don't
connect with this idea of interfere and
going into the layers of the character
and so on but there are a lot of
successful movies that don't have an
inner journey at all those because your
goal is to elicit emotion and if the an
emotion grows out of conflict is the
conflict is so great on the visible
level you may not need the invisible
inner journey level so I don't see much
character arc in any James Bond movie
and they've done pretty well over the
last 50 years 50 plus years now or
Raiders of the Lost Ark I don't see much
of an arc for that character or any
number of other big fireworks special
effects space battle whatever it might
be some of them have an arc for the
character some of them do not some of
them try to but it's
kind of just lesser lesser element but
the movies could be great because
they're exciting and they're
adventuresome and the characters are fun
to watch they just don't have these
deeper layers so that's fine for the
other writer the one who really has a
desire and an understanding of human
nature they have a real advantage at
creating rich three-dimensional
characters but they have a lot of craft
still to learn if they're nowhere near
the first writer you mentioned so in
both cases the writers need have work to
do but the one who understands human
nature but doesn't know craft yet
probably has more work okay great thank
you and if they do the work they may end
up being the best screenwriters because
they're because then I'd be fully fully
cognizant of all of it do you find the
ones that maybe don't let's take the
first one who's no structure perfect you
know structure and and that possibly
there's something in themselves that
they're not addressing and so they're
not able to have their characters go
deeper or is that looking too far into
it where is the one that maybe does not
know some of the structural points but
but is able to really create a rich
character is more in touch with
themselves their emotions their own
identity okay the second character you
just described the one who understands
character depth I have no idea if
they're more in touch with their own
emotions they just understand psychology
they understand the layers of courage
and fear and so on whether they can
apply it to themselves or not I have no
idea because lots of us can be good at
recognizing things and other people and
are blind to what's going on in
ourselves but I will say this for the
for the person who struggles with that
part of the struggle might be that they
don't want to look at the connection
between themselves and what's going on
in their story when I coach people one
of the questions I often say if I'm not
getting a clear picture of the
characters or if I'm
really understanding them is I'll say
the writer where are you in this story
and I'll say I don't mean which
character are you I mean how does this
story reflect something that is
important to you how is it a fluff
reflects something that you're afraid of
that you're resisting or that has been
important to you in the past or whatever
and that's a journey that's hard to take
that's an exploration that's hard to do
if they're willing to do it we can start
seeing that or sometimes and I'm
presumptuous enough of a guy that I'll
mention it but sometimes in looking at a
story and working with someone I can
recognize things about them in the story
that I've recognized in their work or in
working with them that they haven't
discovered and I'll just point it out I
say I will say you know do you see how
this is the character who's really much
more like you do you see how this
character is really struggling with what
you are or I will say have you ever been
in a situation like this what was your
response then why isn't your character
responding something like that so there
are ways to get deeper and go into that
level of understanding through the
psychology of the writer herself or
himself but not all writers are going to
be up for doing that I have to get their
permission to really want to explore
that if they are then it can lead to
some really good things in the script
you